Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David
Pakman Show. I am Jesse Dallimore
sitting in for David Pakman while he
is away. My final day here with you.
This is I talk a lot about Christian nationalism
and the emerging threat the under talked about
and the underappreciated threat of white Christian
nationalism in this country. It has been a decades
long priority and objective to be met by these
Christian nationalists, to intertwine themselves
into government in an effort to take over the
government to force their Christo fascist views
on the rest of us. Are you Jewish? That's your
concern. You are you a nun? You don't have faith.
In whatever religion or religious
tradition. It shouldn't concern you,
even if you're a Christian. It should concern
you. Because the flavor of Christianity,
the doctrinal point of view, will likely not be
the one you share and it will be imposed upon you.
And there are many I mean, we have several
dozens of members of Congress who are now
avowed Christian nationalists who will
jettison any adherence, any loyalty,
any solemn vow, an oath they took to
the Constitution. And my. Who cares?
Because my flavor of Christianity will rule.
It is a dominionism. You should research.
And I'm going to play this clip of this Jason
Ripert, former Arkansas state legislator.
Pastor who is instructing his audience to that
we must take authority over the government.
Do you think that America is going to be free
with a bunch of drag queens running the place?
It is fear mongering, but it is a call to action.
This isn't passive. Well, if if if we end up with
the majority, maybe we can do some good. This is
an active movement to overtake the government and
rule. Watch this clip from Jason Rupert.
Speaker 2: We must take authority.
God told us I'd go out there and be fruitful.
Multiply. Feel the earth subdue it. And have
dominion over everything. Feel the earth subdue
it. To take authority. In France. The reason the
country is struggling. The reason you've got $32
trillion in debt. No, no holds barred. The reason
we come to brinksmanship over and over again
on the national debt is because the Christians
in America have failed to take authority. And
now is the time to choose. Now is the time to
stand. Now is the time to plan. Now is the time
to fight. Now is the time to. To work together.
To save the country. Look, do you think that
America is going to be free with a bunch of
drag queens running this place? No. Do you
think America can remain free and strong with
a bunch of Antifa nuts running around destroying
property? No. And if you're tired of that stuff,
then it's time to make a change. This is a nation
of the people. By the people and for the people.
It was created for you to be in charge. A nation
of the people, by the people and for the people.
So when we have politicians and elected officials
that are corrupt, they need to be taken out,
sent in to jail, send them to prison, just
like I've seen some people do even while I
was serving in the Arkansas legislature. When
you see people like Joe Biden taking taking
advantage of possession and enriching his family
like he has done, it's time to take them out.
Take them out. Remove them. Move them
all. It's time to take authority.
It's time to take authority over everything
in the earth to make a difference.
Speaker 1: Of four and by the people
this country was made for you.
And he's talking to his Christian audience.
This country was built for them. They need to
take it back and rule the country. That we have
a struggling nation. We have a $32 trillion debt.
Doesn't mention anything. About 25% of that 32
trillion being Donald Trump from the possibility.
Doesn't talk about unpaid for tax cuts that led to
that 25% share that stake of our national debt.
Talks about jailing Joe Biden for corruption,
but ignores the rampant flagrant corruption
of Republicans because they're Christians.
They are white Christians who also share in his
dominionism and his outlook. Subdue the earth.
Are we going to be a free country
with drag queens running the place?
Are we going to be a free country with Antifa,
with anti-fascist activists out there that are.
Are they taking away freedom? Are drag queens
taking away your freedom? Do you feel less
free today because. Drag queens read stories to
children at libraries. Jason Raper, thanks so.
It's dangerous. And it's not French. It's
not French. This is this is becoming more
and more commonplace, more accepted by virtue of
it becoming more commonplace. And it is something
that not only we need to keep our eye on, but
we need to be ready to combat it where it is.